it has been 50 years you joined The
Grateful Dead when you were 18 years old
he and I was a senior in high school
yeah and I joined the Grateful Dead
Jerry called me after I saw him play
about two weeks later after he played in
this little Club and I he asked me to
play in a band they'd went in a band I
said yeah that's pretty insane a bad
phone call no no no well first of all
were they called The Grateful Dead at
the time no we had a really bad name
right we're called the warlocks the war
a lot like the male witches Oh in
Dungeons and Dragons that's an eighth
level wizard you both into a locker all
right
so you what did you think of the band's
name when someone came first of all who
came up with Grateful Dead Jerry did
we're sitting on a couch like this and
Jerry had this giant dictionary right
he's just summoned through it nothing's
moving in very much he's not getting
excited about any of the names and
almost setting his finger stops and he
looks frozen and with the words Grateful
Dead Bob and I hated it we argued for
hours after that you hated the name
Grateful Dead how can you call a band
The Grateful Dead and be successful
right
Bill Graham thought the same thing it
wouldn't bill this is the Grateful Dead
and you just stuck with it we stuck with
it it's an amazing name turned out it
turned out too when did you become
convinced it's like three years ago
[Laughter]
walked out here about a half ago maybe
you know what's so funny is that
Grateful Dead famously never a show busy
band but you did do and you talked about
it in the book you have some great
stories and here you talk about going on
this this I never got to watch this show
it's kind of before my time watching
television but playboy after dark off
this iconic show the Hugh Hefner hosted
yeah and it would have people come in
you guys
you tell a story about playing the show
the Grateful Dead played playboy after
dark is that right that's correct yeah
at CBS we were at CBS studio over the
hill here and we were taking our time
getting ready setting up the drums and
everything and playing and you know
doing soundcheck and all of a sudden I
started hearing the strangest thing
camera 13 you're out of focus and then
Oh who's Mike 10 Mike it's not on I
can't hear
I just looked around I started watching
the people and they're kind of loose and
I had this strange suspicion you know uh
Whois Lee is he's a famous a maker of a
certain of thing LSD he had gotten to
the coffee pot it was one of these true
coffee pots stood about that tall had
150 cups of coffee yet and he dosed it
but I was being so the whole crew all
you guys everybody here in the cameras
we're high in acid right wait a minute
so he dosed he didn't know every but he
dose every time so everybody who's
trying to run the show is on acid
exactly right remarkable I thought I
should be a crime I would think I mean
legal in 67 was an illegal back then
wasn't illegal so entire vitamins
whatever you widen coffee back yeah it
doesn't work on me
I'm always acting weird so so so and did
you how did you like did you have to
leave did you get in trouble no not at
all we did the show we did a couple
songs and then Phil Lesh and I'm we're
walking out to the big door and it's
happened there he's like this frozen
against the wall thank you guys
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]